on va ouvrir cette troisième partie avec
un sujet qui fait énormément réagir
depuis ce matin et pas seulement sur les
réseaux sociaux à ça les éditorialistes
s'y sont mis on en a beaucoup parlé et
dans télématin sur france 2 on a appris
que le sénat de l'alabama aux états unis
venaient de voter la loi la plus
répressive du pays en matière div et
j'ai regardé on en parle juste après lé
sénateur républicain de l'alabama des
hommes essentiellement viennent malgré
la résistance des démocrates d'interdire
lé ivg à n'importe quel stade de la
grossesse même en cas de viol seul
exception si la santé de la mère est en
danger dans un pays où certaines femmes
doivent se faire escorter pour avorter
la loi prévoit aussi jusqu'à 99 ans de
prison pour les médecins en géorgie la
semaine dernière a été signé une loi
interdisant l'avortement après six
semaines de grossesse à un moment où la
plupart des femmes ignorent qu'elles
sont enceintes
en tout six états ont déjà légiféré sur
la question car encouragés par leur
président qui multiplie les attaques
contre l'avortement
certains républicains souhaitent à
nouveau porter le débat à la cour
suprême la plus haute instance du pays
où grâce à donald trump
les conservateurs sont désormais
majoritaires alors on a bien compris la
manoeuvre étant effectivement de réussir
à s'étendre sur tout le pays
qu'est ce que vous en pensez on va
commencer par vaux caroline 20 mai ce
qui est très choquant je sais pas si
vous l'avez vu c'est que dans cette
petite salle très mignonne ya quoi il ya
que des hommes y a que des hommes qui
décident et qui votent avec probablement
leur easy plus que leur tête
je ne sais pas avec quoi ils votent pour
remettre en cause un droit fondamental
parce que dans ces cas-là reprenons tous
les droits fondamentaux et refaisons
toute l'histoire des choses pour lequel
on s'est battu depuis en l'occurrence
pour un pouvoir pour libérer les années
70 de quoi je me mêle de quoi je me mêle
au nom de quoi il aurait aujourd'hui il
admet avoir des idées aux gelées
remettre à travailler un débat on peut
admettre qu'il ait des gens qui soient
pour liv et j'ai d'autres qui soit
contre lille et j'ai ce qui la choque
particulièrement c'est qu'il n'ya même
pas j'allais dire de circonstances
atténuantes ou de circonstance qui
ferait que éventuellement la loi
autoriserait lille et j'ai en
l'occurrence le viol en l'occurrence la
seule serait autorisé les cas de 2
de l avis de la femme voilà déjà pas
d'utérus pas d'avis seules les femmes
seraient autorisées à vivre à légiférer
sur mais en tout cas qu'ils aient un
minimum de parité qui soit respectée et
qu'on puisse parler de ce sujet qui
concerne quand même un tout petit peu
plus la robe que l'homme ludivine vous
l'avez dit c'est vrai que c'est la loi
la plus répressive c'est la plus
restrictive également la plus
régressives parce qu'on a l'impression
de revenir 100 ans en arrière ce qui est
trés scandales et aux etats-unis faut le
savoir
le viol est l'un des crimes les moins
punis là bas c'est à dire que pour un
viol dont on peut encourir jusqu'à 25
ans de prison
donc les médecins qui pratiquent les ivg
risquerait d'être encore le plus
longtemps
voilà les médecins risquent jusqu'à 99
ans de prison puisqu'il estime
aujourd'hui que le foetus et ben il a il
a un droit juridique juridiquement il
existe une femme qui attenteraient à la
vie de son foetus serait considérée
comme criminelle et même dans les cas de
fausse couche
on marche sur la tête je crois que la
devise mais god bless america n'a jamais
on n'a jamais aussi bien porté son nom
il faut vraiment que quelqu'un la vienne
en aide pourrait tout à fait précise la
le sénat a voté la loi encore faut-il
qu'elle soit adoptée
1 pour l'instant lé voilà mais c'est
vrai que avec la voilà en suis tombé de
ma chaise ce matin je ne vous le cache
pas en effet voilà ce qui est
regrettable effectivement dans cette loi
c'est qu'il n'y a pas ces circonstances
atténuantes comme le viol et l'inceste
néanmoins je ne suis pas aussi choqués
que vous parce que l'interdiction en mai
l'interdiction de l'interdiction de
lives et j'ai malheureusement dans
certains pays c'est déjà le cas comment
en argentine et au vatican donc on s'est
alors ça existe ailleurs et précisant
d'europe
seuls malte andorre le vatican et san
marin intérieur lives et j'ai ça ce sont
les quatre les quatre pays européens qui
a été interdit après j'estime que voilà
contrairement à ce que tu dis où c'est
une loi c'est gravé dans le marbre je
pense qu'on peut en débattre parce que
nous ne sommes pas dans une dictature
toutes les opinions doivent être
représentées il existe des personnes qui
sont contre les vg il faut entendre leur
âme il ya des personnes qui sont
croyantes et on sait que effectivement
dans les pays où c'est interdit le
dénominateur commun c'est la croyance
par exemple on alabama il ya plus de la
moitié de la population qui se dit très
religieuse
ces percées rita les plus réactionnaires
et
et je pense qu'il faut pas opposer les
pro-life comme on dit et puis ceux qui
sont pour les ivg je pense qu'il faut
que chacun puisse s'écouter de façon à
ce qu'on puisse avancer parce que tous
les avis peuvent s'entendre
oui mais ce qui ne peut pas s'entendre
si vous donnez moi c'est que lorsque
notamment on voit justement ce que vous
appelez les pro-life invectives et des
femmes devant des centres de les annuler
familiaux pour leur dire qu'elles sont
que ce sont des tueuses et que alors
jeté l'opprobe l'est déjà c'est dans une
situation assez compliquée parce que je
ne connais pas une femme qui est avorté
qu'il était fait de gaieté de coeur
à aucun moment donc voilà c'est là
exactement je suis contre ces
extrémismes il faut un débat apaisé
c'est ça le truc c'est que là on a
tendance à en parler avec beaucoup de
l'hystérie il faut que ce soit apaisée
que les arguments puissent échanger
je peux me recule parle d'hystérie non
moi je pense qu'il ya pas de débat dans
cette histoire on peut pas il n'y a pas
de courroux contre lille et j'ai peut
considérer qu'on peut être non pas
contre lille et j'aime et faire en sorte
que les femmes aient le moins recours
ali vg en proposant une contraception en
faisant des cours d'éducation sexuelle
en informant la population parce que ni
vg ça reste un acte quand même important
personnes comme les mcdo de gaieté de
coeur mais le problème dans sa c'est que
on résume souvent le bilan de donald
trump a eu ses performances économiques
le chômage baisse la croissance mais ça
aussi ça fera partie du bilan et
pourtant on entendra très peu parlé je
me retiens dramatique dans cette
histoire c'est que finalement les femmes
qui vont tomber enceinte et deux qui ne
prend pas avorter alors on va mettre de
côté le cas du viol et de l'inceste
parce que c'est vraiment c'est
dégueulasse peux pas en parler c'est
alors à plusieurs choix sur l'argent
d'aller dans un autre état et de pouvoir
faire un avortement soit finalement elle
va faire des méthodes naturelles comme
on a connu ce qu'on appelait et si en
france les tricoteuses oui avant la loi
veil mais heureusement d'ailleurs à
perdre haleine à une augmentation de la
mortalité chez les femmes qui sont
enceintes ou finalement peut-être
poursuivre leur grossesse et abandonner
leurs enfants donc je pense que c'est
vraiment c'est rétrograde et on le dit
très bien c'est que c'est des lois pour
les femmes
votée par les hommes et je pense que si
les hommes avaient l'utérus jamais on
voterait jour de l'an c'est clair dites
nous ce que vous en pensez avec le
hashtag cqdm qu'est ce que vous dites
comme damien il faut arrêter
ce qu'il y ait un dialogue et que en
plus entendre que l'on appelle comme dit
damien les pro-life faut bien vous dit
il ce n'est pas audible
le corps de la femme lui appartient et
il n'y a pas à légiférer là dessus ou au
contraire en tout cas les autoriser à
faire ce qu'elles sont celles dites nous
ce que vous en pensez un hashtag sécu
des lt